[Music]
thank you
I've spent a lot of time on the Smith
breakfast table and for good reason but
does the Smith family really strike
using the kind of family that gets up at
the same time to have breakfast together
and prepare this kind of spread which
part of any of these non-jerry people is
the part that's like ooh can't miss the
good old family breakfast tradition my
inherent love for cinnamentality and
routine will not be denied also if
you're making a breakfast that has
pancakes toast in what looks like mashed
potatoes with rice sprinkled on top of
it but I'm hoping is grits then you do
not need all these what I'm graciously
going to call hash browns I trust no one
in this room because not a single one of
them is drinking coffee and this isn't
caffeine moderation shaming what's going
on here is a statistical impossibility
to those who rushed out and grabbed the
yasica insta handles all I have to say
is that your commitment to mimicry and
parody of this character has been
underwhelming this sin is on your hands
hi I've placed an auto response chip in
my brain so I can spend time with my
family what kind of lousy auto response
chip responds by declaring it's an auto
response chip a terrible auto response
chip that's what any death crystals from
4pogilon Prime show will never explain
what makes the death crystals from
forbogen Prime better than any other
death crystals and if you're gonna say
they only exist on for bogelin Prime
then we never find out why Rick who
cares about nothing cared about
name-dropping this planet dad you hardly
put any syrup on honey stop raising your
father's cholesterol so you can take a
hot funeral selfie but isn't Summer's
logic a bit off here she just said that
the reason funeral selfies are hot is
the grief runs the cheeks but who's
grieving at Jerry's funeral why are they
called Death crystals do they kill you
you're thinking of bullets Morty while
bullets are technically Crystal and
solids this punchline probably should
have been reserved for jokes about death
metal death crystals show you how you're
gonna die then I hereby submit they
should be called cause of death crystals
also expirite was right there the
contrived nature of these rocks is
immediately forgiven because of how much
thought went into coming up with and
animating all the amazing possible Morty
deaths in this episode people that spend
their life avoiding death are already
dead and what's dead may never die so
what are people that spend their dead
lives living death Quantum entangled see
I can sci-fi up some random too the idea
of using the expirite is some sort of
morbidity divining Rod is interesting
and all but no I'm not buying it even if
you did catch a unified glimpse of your
demise every micro movement would
completely change the possible outcome
in a way that would render it no longer
valid and impossible to recover I
thought you were masturbating
you'd rather I address it it's not so
much that I'd rather you did it's just
that it seems pretty in character for
you to do and nothing has stopped you
from doing it before I'm willing to
accept that you're doing this if you're
willing to accept
title of my sex tape it was as if the
Smiths collaborated with their next door
neighbor on this fence since it crosses
both yards and I refuse to believe
there's any Universe where next door
neighbors get along well enough to
accomplish this feat operation Phoenix
something something cloning callback
something something Rick's pixelated
improv the rest is oh I'm guessing this
scene was written but you are down with
fascist dystopias right if you have to
ask your question is obviously more
about dramatic reveals than your
commitment to extremely problematic
political ideologies sitting on the
nasty floor of a school hallway leaning
against the lockers this is your respite
I don't have to be anywhere in the next
few minutes you know where I'm gonna
plop down for conversation
staphylococcus Central that's where
throw that thing in the garbage stop
planning your own death and talk to
whoever you want Rick steals the exact
words I told my younger siblings about
their paper fortune teller oh and if you
don't know what I'm talking about see
also Chatterbox flipper flapper Soul
seller whirlybird Paco Paco or cootie
catcher stop doing meta commentary he
says meta commentarioli
being so worried about scientific
accuracy they make space completely
silent when you know your audience would
rather hear the Nazi Morty choking to
death
these shrimple Ricks yelling at Morty
because verbal abuse is fun does your
house look like a tree or no it looks
like this it's like identical to this
actually Rick and Morty hanging Lantern
on a logical inconsistency thinking that
will somehow keep us from sinning it as
if they've never seen one of our videos
before come on just admit you watch TV
sins already
um cliche I'd remove Us in if I could
say for sure that this sign meant no
flossing but I can't so instead I need
to write you up for improper signage bad
at math but I'm giving you an A plus in
confidence Americans wait isn't that the
same student that was sitting on the
floor earlier are you telling me that
wasn't even their locker they were in
front of you sat down and leaned on
someone else's Locker who does that only
if the events of the Pixar movie Coco
are to be believed which I doubt Coco
deniers I certainly have questions about
how or why Holograms eat but the show is
of course touching on that just enough
to pretend like it actually means
something so instead I'll ask how this
holotech is powered and where it's
physically distributed from the show
gets a lot of credit for thinking
through its theoretical Concepts but
when it comes to technology it lives
firmly on yada yada Avenue will you just
show me how to stay alive Morty is now
asking Hollow Rick to help him not die
instead of Consulting the death Stone
even though Hollow Rick helping him not
die was not presented as an option by
the death Pebble show is all over the
place when it comes to how committed
Morty is to following his new
sedimentary God
Precious Dish
nope
first up I think this is a very funny
recurring gag which is something I never
thought I'd say about fascism second the
writers made a teddy bear rig because of
course that's funny but they also made
him mortal in the same way a human would
be mortal instead of giving him soft and
cuddly entrance as we would expect the
commitment to Teddy Rick was less than
that of pickle Rick who was a pickle all
the way through and that's just
unacceptable bringing a chain to a horny
teenager with a death Crystal fight
sure I'm enjoying the every Rick every
Mort all at Oneness of it all but how is
he able to so quickly identify which
path leads to Jessica when up until now
he had to take time to zero in on it
Shield me from the law cool two me seeks
callbacks in the same episode but
wouldn't these musics have immediately
shielded him from the law thereby
accomplishing their task and
consequently disappeared
really getting all the sounds correct on
the first or second shot there are 44
different phonetic sounds in English
Morty
44. he loves you little Sparrow he's
innocent case dismissed the U.S justice
system I think we're just about ready to
forgive him and move past this whole
thing he's a free young man and as far
as continuity goes the reset button's
been hit what the [ __ ] did you just try
to tell the audience that none of what
Morty is doing in this episode matters
as it relates to the broader storyline
oh it matters and this is not the last
time you will be hearing about it oh
it's nice to know it's also 2 p.m in
every other universe as well I was
beginning to think this clock was just
broken we eat our prey alive and when we
don't we lay our eggs in their eyeballs
so that our young can Feast on their
brains when they hatch nope nope nope
not looking that up here's the sin for
just making me think about it so what
are these wasp nests for if you
furnished a human type house and why is
there a collectible plate on display if
you don't even use plates in the first
place does no one on this show care
about the important things where's my
boggling there you are don't worry Pop
Pop's back goosing the boglin market
directly after I sold my 1987 slurp for
a measly 30 bucks all that's left of
these Kirkland brand me seeks
Kirkland shaming it's funny because he
can't be stung but it's also not funny
because he's been spouting off all
episode about being a hologram so we
know that he knows that we know that he
knows that we know that he knows that we
know that he knows
excuse me
that he's not able to be stung and
that's only because of all the fourth
wall breaking
I have
met for reasons
[Music]
dare I say too fast and only because the
episode is ending soon the runtime
should never dictate the rate of
pupation there's a lesson here and I'm
not the one that's gonna figure it out
is it that Rick and Morty will do just
about anything to make sure they hit
their gratuitous Gore quota am I close
okay fine I'll take the assignment
seriously the lesson is that as Humanity
becomes more and more reliant on
technology to sustain us we're also more
at risk of those same Technologies also
killing us and while it's more likely to
be a dispassionate accident we don't
really know what we're doing and one day
maybe it will be malicious there not
saying I won't do your job for you but
you aren't going to like my consulting
fee I don't want to see any more anime
stuff the comment section when I try to
send my hero Academia somehow makes it
into the episode you ruined the season
four premiere it was already ruined from
the second you decided to take over two
years after season three to bring us any
new Rick and Morty and you know it
foreign
would you please accompany me to forbode
jalon Prime for death crystals you don't
want to sell me death sticks faster good
idea Maureen will get us through these
martinis to a family of immigrants I
don't know how to drink your whole
generation you drink for the wrong
reasons
that's not an integer [ __ ] you science
all that's left of these Kirkland brand
me seeks boxes
Kenneth Kirkland what's with the strut
you think you own the school nope no
matter what you got this stop
those were my husband's last words he
says tell her she's wearing a shirt that
I spilled the margarita on and the
earrings I gave her for Christmas I
guess I gotta learn how to live in the
moment a little more that's why you
always leave a note